there's some great dishes that are made
in rows you already touched on that what
if you guys had to eat brains to survive
and live what would your favorite meal
or dishes be oh and I mine I could have
mine if it's an atty green curry I can I
can eat anything if you if I can eat poo
poos if it was in a green curry I love
green curry I'm right battered and
deep-fried matadv fry pappardelle pasta
some brain ragout hmm no there yeah
probably with uh some macaroni and
cheese yeah it's out of bacon bits brain
bit sounds all right I think I do nachos
with some brains on top hmm I would do
brain parmesan uh-huh shout out to my
vowels Italians yeah I would profit oaky
brain chilly been there done that
I'll go back for seconds all right
thanks thank you thank you
has anybody else dressed up in that are
you the only one I haven't seen any
place so yeah we all go to use how you
come with a brain in a hand
we got the secret details it's awesome
um thanks um now I'm flustered um oh my
question was actually about in the
finale about Natalie she was taken away
for them to you know try some cure thing
on her and that's the last we hear of
her we don't see her or anything so I
was wondering if she's if that's going
to come back into play at all or if
that's the end uh yeah it comes back
into play in as we start season 3 major
is right back on the hunt for Natalie he
wants to figure that out he feels like
he made a promise to her that he did not
keep
and he wants to fix that thank you
whoa all right hi my name is Amy and I'm
from Carson City Nevada and obviously
I'm a big iZombie fan but I'm also a big
Harry Potter fan and I'm part of the
hogwarts running club and one of the
things we do is sort ourselves into the
houses so I was wondering if any of you
identify as belonging to a particular
house slowly name all the house at the
ranges I would be Gryffindor Slytherin
put Blaine and Slytherin thank you
I've got Anders and Slytherin now both
of them I actually did the sorting hat
it said Slytherin but I feel Gryffindor
but it says I'm Slytherin what do you
mean there's a test now you wear the hat
yeah Nutella on your head in it I come
on that's what it is is there is there
like a huff and puff
hufflepuff yeah public okay I'll be
there that's not a house that's not a
house Oh Oh brief endure this is Griffin
doll right yeah Gryffindor for me uh I'd
be Gryffindor yet all right what are you
what are you by the way
what what do you identify yourself as
darlin Carson City I'm a Ravenclaw hi we
are thank you God
popular answer yeah much more popular
than ours yeah I'm a rebel I see them to
people oh yes hello hi I'm Xanthi I'm
from Austin Texas
great tennis I had a question for Rose
or anybody else who wanted to answer and
that's if Liv's abilities have given any
of you inside on a human nature or like
how different ever it is that you maybe
didn't have before you started the show
I actually found the one Brian I've
enjoyed all of the Brian sees different
things about each of them that a like
whether it's learning a physical skill
or humorous or something there's always
something to enjoy and the one I didn't
enjoy playing was the start of season 2
episode 1 where I was like the Archie
Bunker bigoted racist kind of brain and
it was actually probably quite a good
exercise because you know you tend to
hear these tirades that these people say
and feel so strongly like that I just
don't want to engage or think about it
and in a weird way it was it was
definitely kind of like I didn't I
didn't enjoy that episode to film like I
really I found it quite upsetting but
thinking about like trying to understand
where people come from and and where
they're kind of conditioning of their
minds comes from and you know this guy's
in chronic pain and maybe that's changed
his outlook on the world I think like
especially given certain things that are
going on at the moment like it's very
important to to like try and understand
we're thinking that you disagree with
comes from rather than just shutting
your mind to it yeah so that's mine I I
learned a lot I was really touched and
connected most with stripper brain I
honestly really changed how I go about
my day to day life can I tell you
actually we were filming in a strip club
and Allie and I were you know very
professional and we're having to do all
the stuff and there were lots of amazing
dancers around us that is the only day
in two seasons of shooting that role
volunteered to come down and just check
everybody was going okay on and off make
sure that I know we were all well fed
and coffee'd and watered and it was very
present which was strange role actually
I do to tell you one thing about
stripper brain is that there's I threw
in a joke there to a girl that I knew
who was a stripper and was going to law
school and
she graduated this year from law school
yeah I would not name her but she did
and so there bullsháá
her name is not Portia Helvetica not
Helvetica go ask him up with that name
and I think it's the best stripper name
ever what was Helvetica hello Jessica
y'all better come oh my god
pelvic I don't know who's a pelvic von
something I don't think it's a little on
the nose on something thank you oh yeah
thank you hi I'm Bethany I'm from San
Diego my question is for Rose and the
producers what's up with the wig can we
expect eventually maybe a full bleach
for Rose go complete zombie you mean for
me in my real life yeah my hair is like
a bale of hay it's like hot glued on my
head it's so fragile
it's like rubbish this would just snap
if I tried to Rose would be bald in real
life just like any of us would except
out yeah because he actually dyes his
hair what was L is I do i that obvious i
exhume the first season I said to the
boys it was crazy cuz Malcolm had a
tragedy at his barbershop in LA and like
me Buckley role and mouth were literally
a dude's just like talking about hair
like put on a night to show us pictures
bro what's up dude he's so upset and we
sorted it out but then a few days later
I go in and got my hair dyed and I ran
my head and took my hand through it and
it was snowing on my head and I was like
it hurt my scalp hurt then I was like
dude in that same text change I was like
Bros next time you look for me do not
look for David Anders look for young ed
Harris it's going it's happening for
what I've gotta say I let most upset to
just learn that I'm included in these
two like the text chains with the boys
that it is full of toilet humor and like
just real rubbish I get lift off the one
about here that you serious we got our
serious fancy men we were definitely
roses a major trooper with the wig
because just to wear that for like yes
hours a day
she's pretty pretty badass for just
putting up with it I've given her a
couple head massages after work when she
really needs it mm-hmm and we do have a
new wig this year so oh ouch oh no
anybody we're working on it and I also
have an incredibly difficult scalp I
have like really sensitive skin so it I
feel so sorry for the department I mean
they just can't really put any glues or
things on my head because it just
explodes so yeah it hasn't been an easy
one to work out and I think they've done
a great job and we're really excited
about season three how the wigs gonna
look we think it's gonna be even better
I also have to say if that face is there
and you're looking at the wig I really
don't know what to tell you I have no
response to you kind of there's that the
wig it brings up an interesting question
because no one at fillmore Graves has
your look has the zombie look and and
they all believe in tanning and dying
like tan and dye and they actually get
will get on your case about go
undercover
hi Chandler do you think maybe or try it
I don't think so
well and here's the thing in it and it
would make a lot of creative sense for
Liv to try to blend in now and yet the
whole show started with the head of
Warner Brothers television development
handing me the comic book and showing
the front cover and saying this is the
new heroine for the CW go write it and
and that like you are our poster and
that that wig and that hair and how do
you just can house clay hot girl oh
right exactly no I was gonna sign one of
my favorite thing now I don't like about
this whole show this experience is when
I get to come a and meet the fans
because you guys the reason we can do
our jobs we are so grateful it's like
it's an honor and we like interacting
with you all on Twitter and hearing your
thoughts but when I get to see people
dressed as Liv
just like it's it's we film in this
vortex we're we're just on set and we're
creating this thing we don't even really
know what the outcome is going to feel
like and then we get to kind of see that
it's impacted people and that people
care and and want to dress up like her
and want to dress up like a girl who
isn't the kind of girl next door every
woman like she's she's her own thing and
she's eccentric and a striking look and
I feel really really proud to be
associated with that I love that she
doesn't try to fit in she embraces who
she is I actually listen to David Bowie
as the music for love I don't even know
if I told you that I've always listened
like that's my soundtrack because there
is just something about that embracing
you and a freak and that being what's
sexy and beautiful about you so I don't
want live to change alright got it here
hi I'm Madeleine I'm from Southern
Oregon hey man hey David we grew up next
door dude it's true we had shared a
garden and my dad had a garden walked
through the garden and then we walk into
her back yard which had a pool yeah he
learned how to swim and I sure did yeah
yeah I thought this is measure I thought
this using Boise hi Daddy hi I'm I've
also been told I'm the last question all
right yeah um so my question is for the
actresses and the writers with the
culture of feminism right now and
writing your show what themes and
responsibilities do you feel come up for
you when writing strong female
characters Rob I mean it's an
interesting question because like we one
of the things that we said going into
this year was we wanted a like we're
gonna replace Steven Weber with another
big character another guest on not
necessarily the big bad but a morally
complex
occupying the space that we used to have
a big bad and and we wanted her to be
tough and powerful and badass
but you ask yourself the question or at
least I do as a writer than would if she
if she turns out to be bad then are you
sorry are you writing a cool empowering
female character are you writing a bad
guy but I think it's cool I think it's
good I you know it's but it is something
that I that I struggle with is you know
if she is badass and she is smart and
what if she does some evil things is
that an empowering female character on
TV uh answer anyone haha I know I just
think a lot of times when we're writing
or concise it's always in my head and I
always feel this weird pressure and you
could just go down that rabbit hole and
then if you go fully down the rabbit
hole you never do anything and it's also
kind of oddly also disrespectful because
then if I have to worry every time I
write something that I'm making women
look bad then shouldn't I be worrying
about making men look bad and should I
just write women like people and not get
a [ __ ] so uh you know when I was doing
this stripper episode I was like is this
bad and then I thought well there's
women out there who are strippers I
didn't invent it I didn't invent like
this it's just just writing people as
honestly as you can and trusting that if
at the end of the day people have a
problem with it a woman wrote it and
she's an EP and she got paid and she's
fine with it so I feel like um I think
actually having you know over various
pilot seasons and looking at different
jobs over the years I've read hundreds
of acted like character descriptions for
actresses and it's like they're just
there were so many that were like the
the wife of or the girlfriend novel the
daughter of and that was boring and then
there were so many that were like tough
badass that was all they were and that's
just as boring that's not that's not a
complete strong interesting character to
me what I liked about what how these
guys write and I mean you can see it in
Veronica Mars you see it in this show in
various characters I think like there's
power and vulnerability and is
um being a multi-faceted interesting
female who can be really strong and also
can be incredibly weak and need things
that's not something that we should be
showing away from that's something that
it's innate it's a for men and women and
I think sometimes we start to write
these really or I have to read scripts
of these really stereotypical kind of
tough chicks and I just I mean
personally I feel like that's not my
idea of true strength I think like being
able to embrace who you are for whatever
that means is ultimately the the kind of
goal so I feel like these guys have
written a character where I'm not afraid
sometimes to need help I'm not afraid to
offer help I you know she's on her own
journey and that's again not the driving
force is necessarily trying to
communicate something that plays into
everybody else's ideas but just
communicate a real person with real
feelings and and not not perpetuate
ideas that we don't believe in you know
and Madeline I drove by our houses the
other day our old houses they're still
there
I miss them I'm gonna text you later
okay
you